yeah welcome to this video a new game
and I've actually started this a bit
accidentally I am I have some stuff in
the in the kitchen cooking so I'm trying
to to play this this extra quickly to
make sure that my food is not getting
burned yeah I've gotta Trump off scheme
and g-form trying to play aggressively I
mean not trying his is managing to play
recive limit in the process wide also we
can turn his position a bit I'm not I'm
not forced to to Castle short of course
them after opening the G file and so on
I won't um ok so just 97 maybe 97 bishop
FYI every five
yeah no problem I can I can really just
just grab this guy just need one move
here or can I even take H form now you
might take g6 Jung [ __ ] Joo 6 i'll just
go here and casts a long neck smooth
yeah I don't think of that I shouldn't
have any many problems in this structure
looks uh looks fairly fairly healthy so
how to continue its intending to go to
you five of course cannot go Luke v8
yeah maybe maybe like this the edge gone
so i can take but this is this a son
came yawa i didn't pay any attention to
this awesome
yeah okay I'm an exchange down and
that's not I mean Lee ok some he had a
really bad porn structure before that
and if I don't blunder the exchange are
probably just better so I'm it's it's
still possible to to fight it because
the structure remains terrible jump ok
I'll take it I mean f-4s just hanging so
this was so the IDM yeah unfortunately
I'm
if i take that some does it help cam
maybe play this first at the F&H porn
are too weak so taking would've helped
so here ya stand a way to to cover maybe
I can play here attacking attacking the
other porn I still like to continue i
mean if i get them oh no I'm actually
getting f4 if i take here there's this
hanging with check wait i had to put
this this is also hanging insistence
slightly yeah slightly problematic here
so i take him there's no no trick IAM
are lucky okay
okay let this is five against four
points it's not completely easy at least
I hope okay also c4 is not so easy to a
completion
all right let's see let's see how it
tries to win this which has some
fortress-like qualities it's not not
easy to win at least I think so needs to
be a careful at least yeah you can try
that but it's maybe this is too
ambitious let's not play before yeah and
the idea of playing a quick game to look
after my food in the kitchen as has not
worked out but I won't resign this okay
yeah the night on c4 would cover a 5 my
weakness here and I'm always threatening
or go ahead I'm always threatening the a
porn at some stage so now there's no way
to try to win this right I'd like to of
course now if I draw i can i can just
move the Luther King King f6 g6 and so
on he's got no realistic way to improve
at least them I don't see it can try to
check on it on c4 maybe
and I can try a 685 but ok I'm spending
too much time in this is nonsense the
only way yes is to play on time anyway
ok I'll take the a pond and probably the
c3 porn as well
no no no no this I'm trying to win now
I'm warning
those pawns are quick c28 to jack yeah
idiot just an idiot playing on time all
the time yeah yeah you deserve that all
right now I need to check my food